so with my videos on the Infinity
Gauntlet and Iron Man armors being so
well-received and with Deadpool coming
out this week what I want to do here is
start a weekly series called comic book
concepts focusing on the origins or
histories of certain aspects and
artifacts of the comic book universe in
this instance I wanna provide the origin
of the Weapon X project and Marvel
Comics and incorporated into how it was
a deadpool found himself swept up in the
program now before we get into this
something that i want to focus on is the
differentiation between Weapon X as an
organization and Weapon X as a name for
first time comic book readers and truth
the idea of the phrase Weapon X can be a
little daunting and so to clear this up
when Wolverine first appeared in Marvel
Comics while his backstory was largely
shrouded in mystery the only thing
anyone really knew was that he was
somehow granted his adamantium skeleton
by a clandestine organization known only
as Weapon X and so in the face of the
fact that Sabretooth wasn't introduced
until three years later in 1977 and is
one of the most well known participants
of the program during the three years
between 1974 and 1977 Wolverine and
Weapon X went hand in hand giving way to
some fans referring to Wolverine as
Weapon X while the introduction of
Deadpool and several miniseries would
expand on the history of the project
because Wolverine was so popular and was
the quintessential face of Weapon X the
namesake remained a part of his history
even into the current day but also
included some other subjects of the
program taking on the name as a way to
establish their backgrounds and
differentiate them from Wolverine
himself having said that the Weapon X
project was a name given to the 10th
iteration of a joint us-canadian program
devised by weapon plus covered in Grant
Morrison's new x-men issues 145 and 154
Captain America annual 2000 Weapon X vol
2 issues 14 through 20 and 23 Marvel
presents volume 1 issue 72 through 84 as
well as project Marvel's 1 & 2 what
we're told is that around 3 billion
years prior to the development of life
on Earth an organism formed referred to
only as sublime gaining sentience
shortly after and functioning as a
bacterium sublime was capable of jumping
from human hosts to human hosts keeping
itself alive and controlling the Wills
of humanity as organized civilization
began on
now decide check for a second the rise
of sublime actually coincided with the
arrival of the Celestials and the
creation of mutants if you recall my
video on the Celestials we had talked
about how Marvel had created their
backstory in different ways where some
writers like Marjorie Liu had
established his Celestials as being the
creators of life death and the
multiverse all other writers like Jack
Kirby civilly depicted them as wildly
powerful aliens that traveled the
universe creating life on the worlds the
fundamental principle of their existence
still remains and that they had arrived
on earth and planted the x-gene in a sub
sect of humans which would evolve over
the next several million years
eventually giving rise to mutants as a
result when mutants began to develop at
an increasing rate during the 1920s in
the 1930s Sablan viewed them as a threat
to its rule and that the mutant gene
protected mutants from Sublime's ability
to control them and so in 1939 during
the time leading up to American
involvement in World War two
sublime took over a human host naming
itself John after which it started a
secret war against mutants by creating
weapon plus an organization that
masqueraded as a program designed to
provide powers to humans for use in
future Wars but functioning with the
true motive of eliminating mutants while
weapon Plus was used as a hub for
various projects during this time dr.
Abraham Erskine had been experimenting
with creating super soldiers for Nazis
in Germany because Erskine's work
unintentionally fell in line with the
goals of sublime and because America
feared losing the war under the
direction of the US government with
sublime acting in the background Nick
Fury and Howlin commandoes were assigned
the task of extracting Erskine from
Germany and having him continue his work
in the United States under the direction
of sublime and weapon plus to this end
during the events of Captain America
annual 2000 it was revealed the project
rebirth was launched beginning with
weapon 0 a man named Clinton MacIntyre
as the first test subject while Clinton
did not match the moral parameters laid
out by Erskine and that Clinton was
mentally unstable and had a
predisposition towards violence the
failure of Weapon zero came and that
after being provided the Super Soldier
Serum because it enhanced all the
physical mental and emotional properties
of the subject clinton essentially lost
his mind
attacking the military officials and
breaking out of the facility after which
he succumbed to a heart attack and was
placed in suspended animation for future
revival
following this weapon one came in the
form of project reverse second attempt
but dr. Erskine developing the visor a
machine and exposing Steve Rogers to the
super-soldier process leading to him
becoming Captain America however because
Erskine was killed by German spy Heinz
Kruger the Super Soldier Serum and
project rebirth died with Erskine
leaving John sublime without the means
to recreate the process at the same time
because mr. sinister had been obsessed
with mutants during his time as a human
in the 1800s and especially after his
transformation at the hands of
apocalypse during World War two sinister
review Nazi concentration camps as the
perfect place for his genetic
experiments during which time he
analyzed categorized and recorded his
work for those of you who have never
seen my video on mr. sinister he was a
character that debuted at Marvel Comics
in 1987 and was established as being
obsessed with the evolution of humanity
and the development of the mutant gene
where his life would change after
encountering apocalypse and being
granted immortality sinister use his
extended lifespan to experiment and gain
a greater understanding of the mutant
genome something that would become
prevalent in his pursuit of the genetic
offspring of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
having said that with a surrender of
Germany and the liberation of the
Auschwitz concentration camp by Allied
forces sinister abandoned his work
leaving his recordings behind and so
going into the 1950s and an effort to
expand its knowledge on the mutant
genome and use mutants as a way to
provide normal humans with powers
sublime recruited a man named Andre
Fortin for the purpose of gaining as
much information on mutants as possible
during this time weapon plus began a
process of attempting to duplicate the
work of Erskine in a series of projects
designated weapons two through nine
while these sought relative success in
that weapon - was composed of animals
and weapons seven created nuke a human
soldier during the Vietnam War who had
enhanced strength speed and durability
due to the armour implants under his
skin the true success of the program
didn't come until Weapon X in the early
1960s in its original form the first
iteration of Weapon X did not involve
experimenting on Wolverine instead the
organization was wholly funded by the
CIA and maintained a black ops team
called team X composed of Wolverine
Sabretooth maverick
John Wraith Silver Fox and Mastodon
during their time working as agents the
groups serve the purpose of carrying out
covert missions for weapon plus
involving assassinations espionage and
retrieving stolen information at the
same time after each mission the team's
minds were wiped and replaced with false
memories leaving them unable to recall
anything about their lives
aside from functioning as operatives of
weapon plus we're team x would
eventually disband because a group
functions so effectively in the earlier
weapon projects two through nine had
failed or been less effective than
anticipated Webb enacts eventually
expanded into Canada where it maintained
funding from the CIA but operated under
the control of departments K and H to
covert special branches of the Canadian
government with Department K focusing on
spy work and Department H sanctioning
supporting and monitoring all superhero
activity in Canada covered in Weapon X
volume 2 issue number 23 where
Sinister's experiments were still
whispered about by surviving Nazi
scientists the rumors and myths led
Andre Thorton to Auschwitz where he
discovered Sinister's journal containing
a plethora of information on mutants
using as a basis the weapon Plus program
began to focus heavily on Sinister's
work recruiting scientists like dr.
Abraham Cornelius and Carole Hinds to
this end the minds of Tmax were wiped
one final time and they were taken for
experimentation looking to bond
Wolverine with adamantium at the time
where weapon Plus would use Wolverines
healing factor to restore the members of
Team X who were injured on missions
following the transition to Canada dr.
Abraham Cornelius and Carole Heinz
were unaware of the fact that Wolverine
had a healing factor meaning that once
the adamantium bonding process started
Logan's body adapted considering
Wolverine to be the pinnacle of their
work and that the adamantium bonding
made him more durable than Captain
America and his enhanced senses healing
factor and claws made him more capable
web and X began to program will rain for
use as a living weapon by planting false
memories and sitting him through a
series of field tests however at his
conclusion Wolverine killed several of
the staff allowing him to escape the
facility freeing the other members of
Team X in the process now regarding
Deadpool's involvement model has two
reasons for why he joined and they
actually contradict one another and the
original comic Deadpool in death annual
98 the reason behind why way became part
of Weapon X was rooted in the fact that
he simply wanted to be a hero but
looking at the trailer for the movie
they're actually going with the x-men's
origin story of Deadpool developing
cancer and being offered an experimental
cure by the Weapon X program in the
x-men origins story during Wolverines
time as an agent of Team X working for
weapon plus Deadpool was a young soldier
who had enlisted in the US military
while Marvel doesn't provide us with a
detailed account of his actions during
this time what we are told is that after
serving his time in the army Wade
branched out into becoming a mercenary
for hire
using his natural gift for accuracy
combined with his training in the
military way to essentially perform the
same tasks as team acts but instead of
working for an organization wade worked
for whoever would hire him during this
time Deadpool was also in a relationship
with Vanessa Carlysle the woman who
would go on to become the villain
copycat and after arriving back home
from one of his sessions he had been
informed by New York University through
a letter that he had stage four cancer
leaving Vanessa behind in learning about
Weapon X from a fellow mercenary this
period and Wade's life had actually come
following Wolverines escape what I mean
here is that after Wolverine had broken
out of the first facility the focus of
weapon acts became twofold find a way to
recapture Wolverine and then duplicate
his abilities while capturing Wolverine
were proved to be the bane of Webb 'next
existence because the adamantium process
had required tissue samples the
organization still had samples of
Wolverines blood and mutant healing
factor to this end efforts were made to
plant the healing factor in other beings
who either recruited themselves
willingly or else were taken in the
instance of Deadpool while webinar Amane
ambiguous they did offer the possibility
of curing him of his illness where his
body did accept Wolverines healing
factor in an amped-up form it also
caused massive scars and lesions to
appear all over his body
due to his cancer because I goal was to
create superhumans who could act as
moles and different governments or
organizations because Deadpool looks so
grotesque he was considered a failure
and sent to a facility for failed
experiments called the workshop under
the care of dr. Killebrew with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and in tomorrow's video
we'll discuss Ajax and will actually
pick up with this cliffhanger and cover
Deadpool's time in the workshop under
dr. Kilburg that being said I will catch
you guys later please
you